so um we usually do this by hand yes
that one just there that was just adding
up all of these blue values yeah yep so
there's my son there's the cells that
describe it okay all right
we've done most the legwork now this is
the hard part right how do we go from
variance to standard deviation what do
we do John take the square root right so
there's no square root button on our
keyboard again so type in equals to get
a square root you use the abbreviation
that Excel has which is s QR t square
root open a bracket to indicate okay now
I want you to calculate the square root
of this number and to get that cell you
just tap on it yeah after you open the
bracket just tap there and it'll put in
the right cell number for you okay like
so then close your bracket so what's
this mean what we just calculated this
is standard deviation okay now I'm going
to teach you to do something which is
anticipating something we learn later on
how do you read this have a look at what
I've written down here which you
probably have not written yet I want you
to read with me if X is the expected
value or in this case it's also the same
as the mean right then I've got the mean
plus a standard deviation and the mean
takeaway the standard deviation right so
what I'm looking at is what's the middle
of my data okay like there's smack bang
in the middle which is expected value
and then like plus a bit - a bit here's
how we're gonna do it right equals I
want to start with my expected value
which is this number up the top here and
then I want to in the first instance I
want to add my standard deviation so I
just click on the appropriate cells I've
got B 3 plus C 14 okay if I hit enter it
gives me this value and then I want to
do the same thing but instead of add
you're going to subtract so it's type
equals again start with the expected
value which is up the top here and
instead of adding my standard deviation
I'm going to subtract my standard
deviation which is still here okay so
I've got B 3 minus C 14 okay
all right now this is what I get did you
get the same numbers do your numbers
match how's that so what is this telling
us right what did I tell you those nine
numbers were at the beginning what do
they represent
they represent the variables in this
case their heights yeah
the heights of people right so what I've
got here is the middle smack bang in the
middle of the heights is 1.65 meters one
point six six right if I round it
properly okay and this is telling us
want a standard deviation above a person
who's above average height and a person
who's below average height this range
from a metre sixty to a meter 70 you
should find the vast majority of your
people in that range that's why we
calculate the standard deviation and
sure enough just have a look at the data
right I can see this one this one these
I'm just counting all the people in this
range right this one that one's too tall
1.71 is way above that one point six
three is okay this one one point five
five is that within my range no that two
shot one point six is just below and one
point six nine these are okay so you can
see I've got a lot that are just within
that range right and these are called
z-scores by the way we'll get to them a
little bit later on all right are you
happy does your spreadsheet look exactly
the same as mine okay right here's my
next step I want you to take everything
that you just calculated just highlight
the whole thing copy it and then I'd
like you to paste it just beside okay
and we're gonna do some mucking about
with these right now you've got a
duplicate of this data and what I want
you to do is instead of calling this
original data delete rates as original
and what I want us to investigate is
well what difference does it make if we
change the scale of this data change of
scale is what we're first looking at so
I'm gonna right change of scale for
instance you've got these heights
measured in meters what if I wanted to
change this all to Heights measured in
centimeters that's a change of the scale
all my numbers are going to be how much
bigger times 100 right so to Destin
place is gonna move so here's what I'd
like you to do watch carefully for this
pute right take all of the data which we
entered before just to lead all of it
okay just clear it okay you're like wait
why did I why do we bother copying all
of that just to delete the data the
answer is all of my formulas are all
still they're still doing my work okay
just they've got no data to point out
and then here's what I want to do
I turn a hightly meters to in the height
in centimeters what do I do to it
multiplied by a hundred so it equals
right I'm gonna take this height and I'm
going to multiply by a hundred right
that's the asterisk put in 100 and if I
punch in enter is 160 for what I
expected yep there's me turning meters
into centimeters yeah so I've multiplied
by 100 and when I hit enter I get 164
because that's the same height but in
centimeters different units so far so
good
all right the beauty of course of doing
this in Excel once you've written a
formula it's good to go so I'm just
gonna copy that formula and I'm just
going to do the rest of the rows it's
going to look over to the left of the
spreadsheet take all those original
heights and multiply by a hundred which
gives us this okay and the spreadsheet
did all the work right we just needed to
supply the data
yeah it's what which step to join me to
go back to okay you deleted all the
cells so it looks like this yeah okay so
what I wanted to do was take all my
Heights over here and multiply them by a
hundred to turn centimeters sorry to ten
meters into centimeters yeah so that
height multiplied by 100 yep once I've
done that I'm like I don't just want one
height I want all the Heights so I
highlight all the way down and then I've
copied and pasted okay
all right so I'd like you to um take
these values here and we're gonna
highlight them just a little bit okay
highlight these ones here standard
deviation mean plus standard deviation
and mean takeaway standard deviation can
you um color them in red for me yeah yep
oh wait hold on yeah you're talking
about these guys yeah so duplicates so
there's two people of the same height
which is fine which is fine I guess I
could also do this in a frequency table
and say that twice but I can just write
the number twice okay have you
highlighted those numbers in red for me
yeah okay now this is really important
this is a major major deal and we're
gonna write some notes on this in a
second okay I want you to look at the
effect that the change on scale from
meters to centimeters what effect did it
have on these three things down here
compare those red numbers to what they
used to be okay have a look to go from
here all the way over to there what's
the difference what do you see
yeah only go ahead the decimal points
just moved quick question for you how
many places has it moved to places in
other words it's 100 times bigger right
now tell me why that should be exactly
what we expect why are these numbers
like the standard deviation why is the
standard deviation 100 times bigger
the standard deviation let me just
repeat exactly what Sarang said because
you know that right the standard
deviation is proportional to the data
that you put in all of our data is a
hundred times bigger do you agree so
therefore your standard deviation also
100 times bigger your mean also a
hundred times bigger so if you take
those or you add or you subtract
everything is 100 times bigger that
makes sense okay so your expected value
and your standard deviation they grow in
proportion to what have you scaled by
now I want you to have a look at the
variance can you highlight that in a new
color for me let's make it blue for
example now the variance has also gotten
bigger how much bigger is it is it a
hundred times bigger like the mean
understanding ah how many spots has the
decimal place moved its moved four times
right there it is here and I've had to
move it once twice three times four
times so how much bigger is it not 100
times bigger it's it's ten thousand
times bigger okay ten thousand times
bigger now think about this for a second
why is it ten thousand how did we
calculate I'm just going to highlight
the formulas again how do we calculate
variance we take the probability you may
be seen all right you take a probability
and then you're like what's your
distance from the expected value right
that's the distance there but then what
did you do to that distance you you
squared it right so because everything's
a hundred times bigger if you're
squaring a hundred times bigger then
your variance everything is squared in
the variance yeah it's not a hundred
times it is ten thousand it's a hundred
times 100 does that make sense okay so
this is important to jot down right
maybe you want to put this here right
this is a hundred times bigger I'm gonna
make this font a bit smaller so I can
fit it in there let me make that maybe
like a six or to a hundred times bigger
right but this one here this is not a
hundred times bigger this is a hundred
squared times bigger okay I actually
think I have a
differ this let's see if I can find it
there we go
squared Oh
[Music]
all right there we go
okay let me zoom right into that space
just so you can see what I've got there
all right here we go
so our standard deviation and our
expected value 100 times bigger because
you make your data a hundred times
bigger and then your variance not a
hundred times bigger how much bigger is
it 100 squared yeah now quick question
for you let's not do the calculations
just yet if you think about this for a
second with me if you had some unit that
was not a hundred times bigger than a
meter but like say double right what
change would you expect from the
standard deviation from this over to
there if I was increasing the size of my
data by to the standard deviation should
also be increased by two right what
about the variance it's gonna be four
isn't it and I can you don't have to do
this on your spreadsheet but I can do
this quickly and verify this right
remember we said whoops let's delete all
this I'm going to zoom back out there we
go
equals all my original data let's make
it twice as big twice as big so let's
copy all that down have a look is my
standard deviation double what it used
to be I went from point O five to two
point 104 is that double it is have a
look at my variance there I had point
double O two seven is that four times
bigger
twenty-seven times four is 108 so you're
pretty much there right and I could do
this I could keep on changing it but the
importance is the expected value and
your your standard deviation they change
just like your data does but variance
cuz it's all squared
everything gets squared so it gets
bigger by the square all right